Dr kaker is a drug Discovery scientist
and a digital Healthcare Enthusiast he
has a PHD in drug Discovery from Italian
Institute of Technology from Genova
Italy and with several years of
experience in serving clients coming
from Human drug Discovery veterinary
medicine and agrochemical settings Dr
kakar is a strong advocator for using
advanced technology in pharmaceutical
research and development and with that
brief introduction now I'd like to pass
on the stage to Dr Pune Tucker who will
also be the program Mentor for the chem
informatics drug Discovery so the stage
is all yours
thank you very much
and welcome to everybody
um happy New Year first of all
and since we are beginning with this
game informatics size and the
kind of a training program educational
program I see a lot of opportunities in
the uh in this year as well as in the
upcoming years in the 80 of drug
Discovery and development since there's
a significant penetration in the area of
Technology embarking into the process of
Life Sciences and Pharmaceutical
um last couple of years have been very
much evident about how sooner the drug
discovery
should be done rather than this regular
routine exercise of taking 15 years of
time
we have seen the covet penetration how
the human life got impacted how many
valuable lives have been sacrificed with
the infection
and we have seen the power of vaccine
the medicine how
urgently it was required
and the impact of vaccinations is also
very much seen that
um how it could be a life-saving if it
is developed earlier
not just only the covet as a scenario as
an example there are so many numerous
unmet medical needs are in front of us
where drug Discovery is urgently
required where new Therapeutics are
urgently required where Innovative
medicines are are required
without the help of Technology it would
be very difficult to meet that
requirement in a such a shorter time
we believe the incorporation of
artificial intelligence machine learning
and Advanced Technologies even the
Technologies which are not very much
directly evident for example
the
machine learning based GPT
chat Bots are
a a method a technology incorporation
where it can help to search a very large
data set or connect the entities of
pharmaceutical interest together in a
meaningful way
that retrieve a suitable information
that a scientist is looking for a
successful drug Discovery can be so much
beneficial
sometimes think these things are not
very much clear or which are not
directly seen by the people who are into
the early stage of their career
in this particular training program
will not only go through the
traditional ways of
using the technology in identification
of the initial or hit molecules called
hit identification the identification of
chemical compounds that can become a
suitable candidate for the lead as and
eventually as a drug
but also look at a different perspective
how these technology
things should be seen from the angle of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning
in every aspect
right from the beginning of searching a
database
we need to see how we can
automate such processes so that the
larger number screening more
customizable most customized fashion the
data can be retrieved
how you can make the workflows automated
in a way that it should accelerate the
process of drug discovery not completely
end to end the automation order
Discovery but at least some part of that
process
can be automated there are several ways
several Outlook to look at the same
thing in different ways
we will cover those things also in the
exercises that we will be doing in this
educational series
we'll start with some of the
basic databases the content of the
databases and how you interpret the data
in the search publicly available
databases
the very good thing in those publicly
available data sources that they are
freely available
freely available to serve the mankind
freely available so that you can you
should have no boundaries
no boxing in the in the in the thinking
that there are limitations in your in
your mind to develop a new medicines
the data sets are high quality they are
validated they are available to
everybody there is no restriction of how
much you can download there's no
restriction of is stopping anybody to
use these data set
so publicly available data sets will go
through will understand their files will
understand their processes will
understand how differently you can
utilize those datasets
will go to the basic and simple
we had very powerful traditional methods
of drug Discovery utilizing those
individual set of data sets many times
we can we can do fancy stuff but it's
difficult to understand the underlying
concept of how we are using it why are
we using this
is there any best way out of there is
there any alternative advanced
technology way there are there ways
where certain methods will be replaced
in the future for example protein
modeling the traditional ways of protein
modeling have been replaced completely
replaced by the artificial intelligence
method now
thanking someone doing PhD work in
molecular modeling would be very rare I
would say very rare or maybe requiring a
very very complex study that is required
to be done in a PhD work
but uh
most of the times the structures are
either available the key structures or
if they are not available they are
available by means of alpha 4 or
3D structure prediction predicted by the
artificial intelligence method
we'll go through some of the complex
um methods and Technologies for example
molecular dockingbase screening chemical
similarity search screening right
um
so these these screening methods are
very simple but very powerful now you
need to see the same data set can be
done with the help of machine learning
and artificial intelligence where you
can apply what are the opportunities
what are the challenges
every technology every method developed
in the past or currently or they will be
developing in the future they will
always have the limitations and
opportunities
so we need to always balance out the
things when to use which method what is
the ideal way to do that what is more
demanding in here in your
in the in the global scenarios in terms
of career objectives future career
um Ambitions and what are the areas
where the employability is high that
also we will look into some of the
details so overall this training program
this educational series is packed with
full of learning
mixing the traditional as well as
advanced technology in place with the
Outlook of Consulting saying what to use
when to use
and what is the best way to use
I will be taking some of these sessions
there and I hope you will be
enjoying the session it will be a very
very
um learning inspiring sessions for all
of you
looking forward to see you in the class
thank you very much